Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Gisela Giardino
Estas vacaciones
me fui a Barcelona con mi mamá.
Un día quisimos ir
a hacer un picnic en un parque.
Ella ya había estado ahí.
Entonces me dijo
"Bueno, nos tomamos este subte,
hacemos combinación acá,
y nos bajamos allá".
¡No le entendí nada!
Yo de Barcelona lo único
que conocía era a Messi.
Entonces, agarré Google Maps
y me fijé maneras de llegar.
La primera opción que aparecía era
un bondi que tardaba la mitad del tiempo.
Entonces le dije "Mirá má, este va por
un camino mucho más corto y rápido".
Lo miró así como medio de reojo y me dijo
"No, vamos como dije yo".
Me quedé muy mal; me sentí muy frustrado.
No entendí qué pasó.
Y esta es la impotencia que siento
cada vez más seguido en los últimos años.
De tener la respuesta para algunas cosas
pero no poder usarla.
Y no porque no quiera
sino porque no me están dejando.
Mirémoslo así.
Por un lado, tengo un libre acceso
a la información.
O sea que, teniendo conexión a Internet,
saco mi teléfono y pim, pum, pam,
puedo saber cosas desde por ejemplo
a qué velocidad habría que pegarle
una cachetada a un pollo
para que se cocine
(Risas)
hasta cómo llegar a una plaza
en una ciudad desconocida.
Y no solo eso, no puedo no estar
al tanto de las redes sociales.
O no tener un celular.
Porque, tarde o temprano, quedaría
desactualizado y afuera de todo.
Y por otro lado, toda esta
información choca de frente
contra una pared enorme:
los adultos.
Por ejemplo, hace unos meses
quise salir a andar en bici
por primera vez con mis amigos
y mis papás no me dejaron.
"Sos muy chiquito, todavía no podés".
Chiquito ¿para qué? ¿Qué cosa no sé?
Si ya sabía andar en bici y había
googleado cómo ir y cómo volver.
Y acá es donde mi cabeza estalla
porque entra como en un loop.
Al tener acceso a tanta información
me siento presionado,
hasta incluso empujado,
a entrar al mundo adulto.
Es como que me dijeran
"Bueno campeón, tu adolescencia terminó".
Pero tampoco me dan el derecho a decidir.
Entonces, esa adolescencia
que estaba por terminar
se termina haciendo eterna.
Entiendo que me falta experiencia.
Cuando mis papás
no me dejaron salir a andar en bici
no les hice caso y me fui con mis amigos.
Andando en la bicisenda
se nos cruzó un perro sin correa.
Casi lo piso.
Claro que jamás podría haber
previsto eso.
Pero creo que mi falta de experiencia
no justifica un
"No podés porque sos chico",
como única respuesta.
Me parece que hay un problema nuevo
en la relación con los adultos.
Antes la información
y el derecho a decidir
estaban juntos en una misma persona.
Ahora hay veces en las que
yo tengo tanta o hasta incluso
más información que ellos.
Y creo que esto debería darnos
a los jóvenes
la oportunidad de ocupar
un lugar que hoy no tenemos.
O darnos más libertad en la toma
de nuestras propias decisiones.
Algo tiene que cambiar.
No sé cómo van a ser estos cambios.
Aunque hay algunas cosas que me dejan ver
más o menos por dónde va la cosa.
Por ejemplo, cuando volvimos
de las Olimpíadas de Química,
mi profesora nos propuso
a tres compañeros y a mí
ayudarla a editar errores de la guía
y a inventar nuevos ejercicios
pero, además, lo mejor de todo fue que
en la guía puso nuestros nombres
junto al de ella.
¿Qué profesor hubiese hecho
antes una cosa así?
Y en casa también me están empezando
a dar un lugar distinto.
Mi papá, que es abogado,
este año se inscribió para
la carrera de Psicología.
Y tenía que rendir Biología,
que digamos que no es su fuerte.
Ahora, cuando se enteró de que
me iba bien en esa materia,
me dijo "Pibe, hasta que no sepa lo que
es una procariota no salís de acá".
(Risas)
Y ahora, cada vez que nos sentamos
a estudiar juntos,
siento que estoy
con un compañero más del colegio.
Estoy seguro de que el vínculo
con los adultos va a cambiar.
¿Saben por qué?
Porque cuando fuimos
a ese parque en Barcelona,
fuimos en subte como dijo mi mamá.
Pero a la vuelta,
volvimos en bondi.
(Aplausos)